[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory the
time has finally come the long
anticipated trailer for the new
fantastic beasts film the secrets of
dumbledore a teaser came out a couple of
days ago but was pretty short and still
left a lot of us wanting but fortunately
just a few short hours ago we were given
a full two and a half minute trailer
that gave me chills let's break it down
if you listen closely enough the past
whispers to you that's the first line we
hit with as the notes of the magical
score begin to play in the background
the trailer starts with a familiar scene
hogsmeade a place not far from hogwarts
that we know from the harry potter films
we're here to see albus dumbledore says
newt to the unidentified figure
that would be my brother he replies
what that line reveals is that this
figure is none other than aberforth
dumbledore who appears quite a bit in
the harry potter films and of course
works as owner and barman of the hogs
head in in hogsmeade i knew that
dumbledore's family were going to find
their way into this film at some point
so i'm quite excited next we see a
lonely looking dumbledore walking alone
in the snow in what appears to be new
york the next scene is quite important
as it reveals an all-new wizarding world
location that we've never seen before
people are joined together in
celebrating well most likely grindelwald
as it was revealed in the teaser trailer
that he seems to have gained some
traction and gotten quite popular in the
background we see a banner that says the
following heifer suprema which in
portuguese means supreme boss jk rowling
hinted over and over again that we would
see brazil make an appearance in this
movie it looks like this is the first
time we're actually seeing it the banner
also appears to say confederacao
internationale de brujos which of course
means international confederation of
witches next we see the new grindelwald
mass mikkelsen pulling what appears to
be memories out of what appears to be
yusuf karma's head we saw this same type
of spell used with slughorn in the half
blood prince
next we see newt using a makeshift raft
to traverse a river along with his
bowtruckle companion picket next we see
a scene that we actually had a look at
in the teaser which shows dumbledore
saying to an unidentified figure if
we're to defeat him you'll have to trust
me still not sure if this figure is
theseus or bamberforth dumbledore
although i'm still leaning towards
theseus in the previous films theseus
and newt had a bit of a bizarre
relationship but it looks like it heals
a lot in this film next we're back to
newt who appears to be searching in some
kind of jungle my bet is that this is
potentially the amazon rainforest
located once again in brazil
next we're back to new york for a second
where we see theseus valley hicks
ilvermorny professor and presumably soon
jacob walking through a brick wall
i know it's not diagon alley where
they're going but it reminds me a lot of
it in the next scene we see newt all
alone walking into what appears to be
some kind of temple in the mountains i
know that the film is set somewhat in
bhutan a landlocked country in the
eastern himalayas located between china
and india so i'd be willing to bet that
this is where newt is here as
topographically it would make sense
newt looks pretty concerned here so i'm
willing to bet that this is some kind of
grindelwald campaign rally in the
background we hear this is the team
that's going to take down the most
dangerous dark wizard in over a century
a magistologist his indispensable
assistant a wizard descended from a very
old family a school teacher and a muggle
as he's saying this was shown all of
these characters first newt then bunty
then yusuf then lally hicks then of
course jacob next we see something truly
bizarre on what appears to be betraying
newt saying to jacob dumbledo asks that
i give you something right before
pulling out a wand and handing it to him
i really don't know what this means for
jacob's character as a wand is useless
in the hands of a true muggle does this
mean that jacob has nascent magical
ability only time will tell but i'm
excited for this next we see a
gryffindor quidditch student flying
around the ground of hogwarts on a broom
following this we see newt jacob lally
and theseus walking through the walls of
hogwarts then we see them in the great
hall with dumbledore who's casting some
kind of spell that can't quite identify
it looks like he's showing them a
landscape or something next we see
aberforth and albus interacting with one
another without before saying off to
save the world are we in quite an
unimpressed way
this is the first scene where we see
them interacting with one another and
paints quite an interesting picture of
their relationship next we see another
grindelwald rally likely the same one
from brazil
next we see credence sporting his new
long hair being paid a visit from
phoenix we don't know for sure yet but i
think this phoenix is probably forks
next we briefly see jacob and queenie
embracing one another in a hug and
following this we see something quite
pivotal to the story dumbledore
analyzing what appears to be a kind of
pendant this pendant however is
certainly no ordinary piece of jewelry
as it actually relates to the blood pact
the dumbledore has with grindelwald
sealed by blood with dumbledore
analyzing it quite so closely it could
suggest that he's trying to figure out
how to break it next we see newt and
theseus interacting with a vast number
of magical looking crabs just before
being attacked by what appears to be
some kind of giant magical scorpion
next we see theseus finale hicks
battling with four of grindelwald's
acolytes in what appears to be china or
perhaps bhutan and following this we see
jacob holding his wand with purpose as
seemingly queenie and others approach
him following this we see credence along
with vinda rossier and someone else i
can't quite identify approaching some
kind of magical barrier in the forest
credence begins to cut through the
barrier and the colours actually
appeared to quite closely resemble the
moment that voldemort used his magic to
plow through the barrier around hogwarts
next we see newt running up a staircase
towards someone likely in bhutan and
following this we see grindelwald
pointing his wand and yelling our war
with the mughals this also appears to be
in bhutan following this we get a bunch
of quick cuts first dumbledore looking
shocked then use of karma casting a
spell
following this we see grindelwald in
some kind of a bath looking annoyed and
casting a spell at what appears to be
credence just before operating in front
of him and choking him
i wonder what this could mean for their
relationship this scene is full of
tension next we see credence full of
anger running through the streets
destroying buildings and causing all
sorts of havoc running directly at albus
dumbledore following this we see
credence actually attacking dumbledore
just before dumbledore operates away
next up we see dumbledore in what i
previously identified to be the room of
requirement with lally hicks jacob
theseus and newt all approaching
newt even says it in the trailer the
room we require
dumbledore motions his head towards some
kind of rotating ancient pillar or beam
which then transports them somewhere
next we see newt tangled up being
carried through the air by some new
unidentified magical beast and what
appears to be the rainforest maybe newt
doesn't know how to control these
brazilian beasts as well as he thought
next we see pickets running with what
looks to be someone's wand following
this we see credence casting a really
badass looking spell at dumbledore who
doesn't appear to be worried in the
slightest this is one of the first times
that we truly see dumbledore's power on
display
back to the great hall we see lally
theseus jacob dumbledore newt and what
could possibly be mcgonagall in the
background
in the final scene of the trailer we see
jacob interacting with hogwarts students
further suggesting that he is magical at
least in some way
and that's pretty much it we also now
have a confirmed release date of april
2022 which is nice considering how many
pushbacks we've had on the film to date
are you guys excited comment any
interesting things that you saw down
below
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams forget to live
[Music]